[Musik]
[Applaus]
herzlich willkommen am zauberberg im
gleichnamigen roman hatte thomas mann
eine schlittenbahn vom einstigen
sanatorium schatzalp hier runter nach
davos beschrieben einerseits als strecke
für den abtransport der tuberkulose
leichen andererseits als ort für
eigenartigen winterspaß mit mode
spielzeug kinder schlichen wir wird man
uns heute aber nicht manns welt
literatur sondern diesem klassiker hier
dem legendären davoser schlitten der
seit bald 150 jahren jeder mode
widersteht
[Musik]
um mehr über den davoser zu erfahren
mache ich mich nun auf zu einer
schreinerei während ich das tue schaute
heim heute der mann aufs kind wir
wechseln uns in der brutpflege so gut es
eben geht ab und das ist hierzulande
nach wie vor typisch kommen kinder ins
spiel leben wir schweizerinnen und
schweizer meistens und aus ganz
unterschiedlichen gründen das klassische
rollenmodelle der vater bringt die
brötchen nach hause die mutter streicht
sie für die kinder und spült danach das
geschehen
morgen kommt ein neuer dokumentarfilm
ins kino der dieses rollenverständnis
hinterfragt seien weniger titel von der
rolle
hier haben die väter die hosen an und
waschen sie auch der dokfilm von der
rolle gibt einen intimen einblick ins
leben der paare bei denen vor allem die
männer den haushalt schmeißen und die
kinderbetreuung unverblümt sprechen sie
über frust und freude mitspieler so gut
beherrscht
der 100% hausmann kennt keinen einzigen
anderen hausmann
er ist ein exot in der schweiz wo 80
prozent in einem traditionellen
familienmodell leben sich mitteilen
wollten die exoten sehr wohl dass
anleger dass sie wirklich haben
das geht an die gebote des lohns
probiert und es funktioniert die
regisseurin begleitete die paare über
drei jahre hinweg
sie zeigt ihren alltag nicht spektakulär
aber eindrücklich authentisch die rollen
sind zwar unkonventionell aber doch klar
verteilt zumindest bei olivia die 100
prozent als controllerin arbeitet und
sandro dem hausmann überzeugung
verkrustete rollenbilder die nimmt der
film in animationen humorvoll aufs korn
sie basieren auf den eigenen erfahrungen
der filmemacher denn regisseurin verena
rentner und filmproduzent daran riesen
sind ein paar
sie teilen sich erwerbsarbeit und die
betreuung von sohn kim zu gleichen
teilen die bezugspersonen im alltag
erlebt also auch der vater und mutter
und sohn
vorbild war und er aufgeben das ist
heutzutage wird es noch viel zu wenig
verkrampft
auch ein paar im film teilt sich die
betreuung des sohnes und die hausarbeit
ebenbürtig auf musiker theo und tänzerin
meyer diese rollenverteilung will tücken
freiheiten müssen immer wieder neu
ausgehandelt werden und für die
klassische zweimal verlobt aber der witz
schlecht ertragen müssen irgendwann halt
anders machen
so anstrengend das ringen um freiräume
ist beide wissen wofür sie es tun
für eine starke bindung zu ihrem sohn
[Musik]
man bekommt ein paar ein kind folgt es
wieder stärker den traditionellen
rollenmustern nur einer von zehn vätern
arbeitet teilzeit nur eine von zehn
müttern verdient mehr als ihr partner
oft ist sie in der rolle der kuchen
backenden hausfrau gefangen
[Musik]
katrin arbeitet 80 prozent als juristin
der mann martin ist polymechaniker und
arbeitet 60 prozent das ist die typische
männerberufe nicht unbedingt gang und
gab es dagegen zielt also finden ein
interview in ordnung rollenmuster zu
durchbrechen erfordert und dazu will der
dokfilm animieren gesellschaft ist nur
für echte gleichberechtigung braucht es
noch so manche veränderung der film von
der rolle ermuntert dazu die eigene
rolle zu überdenken und
warum nicht es dann tatsächlich anders
zu machen
[Musik]
klasse sowie einschnitte wie mir sie
produziert und dort sehe ich jetzt
gerade noch das ganze werk und vom
wagner dass das ist die schlichte
schmidt eschenholz baut wurde und das
ist auch absolut besser als das ist also
weiß er betrifft weist du geschichte 888
ganz offiziell trägt oder in der bus aus
der wurst sport schlitten tätig ganz
klar deine flachstahl kuchen und
eschenholz das sind ja wirklich wichtige
teil wozu mit der rose schlägt gehört
und dann anhand von dem hai natürlich
logisch beim aufbau kostet bis 700
frankreichs luxus produkt verkauft
also wenn man einsieht und heimweh
binden ganz klar
viele gruppen aus kaufe das geschenk
verpackt sieht für genau das ist auch so
machen
das trägt mit dem reduzierten also
lockerer geworden wie viel machen treppe
mir machen ja frau hat sich jetzt das
allerletzte vier jahre oder drüber halt
so hat sich zeigt dass man ein tor her
15 bis 20 jahre jung ja genau und
äußerte überdies launisch oder kurz es
geht doch nur einmal und den 22 homepage
den 370 auftrag ebenso gern als
liebhaber weg sondern auch bühne des
lebens
das ist rechtlich aus unserem anfang
entstanden will man gemerkt denn so viel
rückmeldung büro wo alte lied wo und
geschrieben hat sich gegen jährige habe
ich weniger starts christ und und gegen
herrn dr
da sind so viele leute geschichte und
das wirklich bewegen hier wurde butter
hat und david weil die chinesische das
ist schweizer kulturgut das ist der
wasserstand der holzschlitten kundigen
jetzt das spiel sind
das verbindet heute mit dem das mit kuba
ist schon eher zentral dass nicht
plötzlich in bayern gelandet ist eher
schwache vertrauen schwingt spd mit ja
das ist ja eigentlich schon
der bergbau hier ist auch wie es ist
präpariert und wieder und natürlich dass
sein team das ganze nie wie viel
promille das ist das natürlich so ich ja
das vertrauen es ist ja auch ein etwas
überreizte begriff alle welt buhlt um
unser vertrauen politiker
sicherheitsfirmen soziale plattformen
medien ja sogar die wissenschaft derweil
ist in allen möglichen bereichen von
vertrauensverlust die rede und weil uns
diese darstellung wiederum sorgen
bereitet lassen wir uns zum beispiel
lieber gleich selbst überwachen
zur sicherheit aber wollen wir das oder
ist es vielmehr an der zeit proaktiv
wieder mehr vertrauen zu wagen so wie es
der philosoph martin hartmann in seinem
neuen buch vorschlägt auch dass wir
nicht in misstrauen erstarren sondern
gemeinsam vorankommen
guten abend
das vertrauen in viele schweizer
institutionen sagt ab zehn jahre nach
der finanzkrise können wir wieder
vertrauen haben droht der medien
diesel skandal
drückt olic
bespitzelung bei der credit suisse
missbrauch in der katholischen kirche
umfragen konstatieren eine immer größer
werdende vertrauenskrise in der
bevölkerung immer weniger
haben wir also das vertrauen ins
vertrauen verloren
dieser frage geht martin hartmann nach
in seinem eben erschienenen buch erklärt
er das vertrauen zur unsichtbaren macht
also wir sind heute umgeben von dem
krisen diskurs überall krise des
vertrauens das bestätigen alle umfragen
vor allem was die politik angeht aber
auch andere institutionen und das heißt
wir sind auch als bürgerinnen und bürger
die wir anderen macht anvertrauen
verletzlich unser interesse stehen auf
dem spiel dinge die uns wichtig sind
oder die wir wollen oder die wir
brauchen unsere sicherheit all das was
wir geschützt sehen wollen von politik
und was er auch verspricht zu schützen
vertrauen für hartmann existenziell
vertrauen ist wie die luft zum atmen
solange alles in ordnung ist bemerken
wir sie gar nicht wir bemerkten nicht
einmal unser atmen
doch wehe die luft wird uns abgeschmiert
das hat silvia sasse am eigenen leib
erfahren die literaturwissenschaftlerin
wuchs in der ddr auf einem staat der
keinem und dem keiner vertraute ich habe
vertrauen ist überhaupt keinen begriff
den man benutzen in solchen staat weil
man hat kein vertrauen gegenüber den
staat oder gebiet mit den medien das
wäre sehr naiv vertrauen zu haben und
der staat will auch gar nicht dass man
ihm vertraut man will ja eher dass man
ihm fürchtet für ein neues buch hat die
slawistin zur desinformation geforscht
sie analysiert wie geheimdienste zu
zeiten des kalten krieges system
kritische kulturschaffende mit
unwahrheiten diskreditiert haben weil
diese das lügen system des staates
entlarven wollten
während lügen zu den mitteln eines
unrechtsregimes gehören rechnet man in
demokratien nicht damit umso
alarmierender ist es wenn auch hier die
wahrhaftigkeit schaden nimmt und dadurch
das vertrauen erodiert wie zuletzt
öfters was sich geändert hat heute ist
dass wir nicht mehr genau wissen wer
eigentlich vertrauen können wenn sie
wissen dass es propaganda es gibt nur
eine zeitung dann können sie das ad acta
legen und sagen nein dem vertraulich die
ich habe heute geht es darum dass wir
permanent neu entscheiden müssen was ist
propaganda was ist das information was
ist nicht desinformation doppeltop
provoziert geradezu diesem taumel indem
er unliebsame fakten zu fake news
abwertet und fake news zu fassen erklärt
scheint etwas an diesen offenen lügen zu
geben was manche leute fasziniert oder
was ganz schlimm sogar vertrauen in ihn
erweckt dem kann ich meine stimme geben
und das heißt das was wir tun in der
politik wenn ich immer meine stimme gebe
ich vertraue ihm macht an und das ist
etwas eigentümlich ist und da müsse man
vielleicht überlegen warum machen die
leute das und dann könnte es sein dass
ihr wie beeindruckt sind von der
frechheit dieser person von der
offenheit ja so würde ich auch agieren
oder ich leg doch auch oft im alltag
wenn es mir passt das hat vielleicht so
etwas wie so eine perverse nähe zwischen
mir und dem denen da oben die dazu führt
dass ich denke der ist ja irgendwie ich
ein tramp ist das interessante dass er
wirklich überhaupt nicht mehr daran
interessiert ist sich zu entschuldigen
für eine lüge dass er einfach weiter
das ist wie ein obszönes lügen nun also
er verantwortet sich auch nicht mehr
verlieren und das ist wirklich finde ich
eine neue dimension innerhalb des
politischen man verbirgt das leben nicht
mehr so wenn man lügt offen
und so hat einer chancen wiedergewählt
zu werden nicht trotz sondern dank
seiner lügen denn seine wählerschaft
vertraut ihm weil er sagt was ihrem
weltbild entspricht dabei sollte das
schenken von vertrauen nicht aus
eigeninteresse erfolgen sondern
zugunsten des allgemeinwohls wie bei den
händen auf römischen münzen als symbol
der fidesz des vertrauens sind sie zum
frieden ausgestreckt denn vertrauen
bildet den kids der gesellschaft
hartmanns buch ermuntert denn auch mehr
vertrauen zu wagen selbst wenn wir uns
dadurch angreifbar machen
dann vertraue ich mir etwas an was mir
wichtig ist mein kind zum beispiel oder
meine nähe und der könnte wenn er wollte
meine verletzlichkeit ausnutzen wenn ich
vertraue gehe ich davon aus dass das
nicht passiert also dass meine
verletzlichkeit nicht ausgenutzt wird
das ist für mich so der kern des
vertrauens darauf setzt auch die werbung
zitiert regelrecht nach unseren
vertrauen
[Musik]
zu anderen menschen
obendrauf
erst der anfang
überall vertrauen alle wollen vertrauen
ich nenne das die fülle des vertrauens
und das hat mich irgendwann auch r
schlag als ich das wahrgenommen habe
selbstmarketing leute wenn man mit ihm
redet und sagt leute ihr wollt produkte
verkaufen oder nein uns geht es um
vertrauen die waren richtig entsetzt als
ich das gesagt habe
aber es ist letztlich ein ökonomisches
verhältnis lose um gewinnen geht und das
verdecken die zum vertrauen warten kommt
daher misstrauen zu lassen wenn wir
aufgefordert werden zu vertrauen dass
man überhaupt misstrauisch sein da ist
auch die voraussetzung höher
kritikfähigkeit und ich denke das
zeichnet demokratische systeme aus man
muss nicht blind vertrauen es ist nicht
per se gut zu vertrauen und misstrauen
ist nicht per se schlecht
und so gilt wir müssen vertrauen in
unser eigenes vertrauen indem wir auch
misstrauen in gesundem maße
ist doch logisch spritzt denn der letzte
teil der boden wie lange ein
wenn wir aus dem stück würde mache eine
knieverletzung dazwischen sächsischen
gestimmt warum wir jetzt machen wir
jetzt mit 40 minuten zwei farben
schwarz-rot-gold ja liter sind ja
nummerierten das feld bis auf die
schlitten
das ist locker machen das aus dem reich
der vorher wo mit dem untertitel lautet
so des rederechts denn für ihn gab es
nicht aber es ist ja nicht so schlimm
wenn es nicht für immer habt danke danke
[Musik]
aus dieser idyllischen schweizer
traditionsreederei blicken wir nun auf
herbe realität in großbritannien dort
erobert rapper storm sie die charts er
beeindruckt mit gewaltiger lyrik und
politischem verantwortungsgefühl setzt
sich ein für die unterschicht und gegen
das stift ästhetisch und fakten
government in faktor für alle die wenig
mit solch markigen rap anfangen können
vertrauen sie uns storm sie alias
michael mary ist eine entdeckung klug
und feinsinnig eine irre gewinner ist
von stones legende ron wood letzte woche
an den brit awards gearbeitet strom sie
bester britischer künstler nach 2018
bereits zum zweiten mal das ist sein
revier
da kommt er her der süden londons hier
ist die musik entstanden die gerade ganz
großbritannien begeistert und darüber
hinaus crime erzählt vom leben das ein
bisschen wilder ist als im rest der
stadt ganz sicher ärmer strom sie hat
sie vom rand in die mitte des
vereinigten königreichs gebracht
als erster künstler steht er auf platz
eins der charts
und er ist es auch der als erster
schwarzer überhaupt auf dem legendären
glastonbury festival als headliner
auftritt das war im vergangenen sommer
200.000 besucher das bühnen-outfit
design von banksy er soll der auftritt
seines lebens werden doch dann fallen
seine milito kopfhörer aus ich stand auf
der bühne wollte einfach nur weinen ich
dachte du bist ein idiot du hast es
verbockt 20 minuten auftritt wird ich
mich einfach nicht mehr aber ich hätte
weiter und sasha und die schlagzahl doch
sie hat es verpasst schlechteste
glastonbury auftritt aller zeit
sturm seelände tatsächlich auf den
titelseiten als anführer einer neuen
generation seinen auftritt verwandelt er
in eine feier schwarzer kultur ein
zeichen gegen den erstarkenden rassismus
[Applaus]
[Musik]
zum finale holte er dann einen ganzen
gospelchor auf die bühne und überlässt
ihnen die show das publikum aus weißen
mittelschicht kids feiert zur schwarzen
kirchenmusik
ich bin nicht er auserwählt nicht da
eine vorzeige schwarze der es gepackt
hat in unserer welt herrscht oft die
vorstellung einen schwarzen den können
wir verkraften
aber es ist meine pflicht hier zu sagen
ich bin nicht der einzige schwarze etwas
drauf hat
nein nein das sind ganz viele von uns
und wir sind könige und königinnen und
es geht dabei um alle es geht hier nicht
nur um mich stumm sie verändert jetzt
schon die starre britischen
klassengesellschaft an der elite-uni
cambridge finanzierte stipendien für
schwarze revolution durch bildung in
großbritannien spricht man inzwischen
vom store sie effekt weil sich infolge
seiner aktion immer mehr junge schwarze
an den universitäten bewerben
wer sein gegner ist wird schnell klar
premierminister boris johnson seine
zeile faktors spricht vielen hier aus
der seele
[Applaus]
[Musik]
erst zu unverhohlen rannten und
rassistisch komplett ungefähr zehn für
ihn aus briefkästen wenn die person an
der spitze das sagt ist es in ordnung
das heißt es ist legitim sei etwas zu
sagen er hat keine achtung vor
bestimmten schichten seine politik hat
nichts mit unterstützung zu tun oder mit
gleich wichtig er hat einfach keine
achtung
deshalb habe ich keine achtung vor
harry ist erhält so heißt unser
aktuelles album schwer ist der kopf der
die krone trägt ein shakespeare zitat
mit dem er sich wieder ganz britisch
zeigt aber auch ausdrückt dass es sich
seiner rolle nicht immer gewachsen sieht
[Musik]
ich kann unmöglich so tun als ginge es
mir immer gut
das ist nicht die wahrheit an manchen
tagen habe ich das gefühl das ist alles
viel zu viel ich werde es alles nicht
ich will diese karriere nicht nicht
dieses leben ich diese verantwortung
ich will mit all dem nichts zu tun haben
sponsel ein rapper der großbritannien
auf den kopf stellt und das mit stil und
anstand
[Musik]
b
am fünften märz ist sie übrigens im
zürcher extra zu sehen und ebenfalls
nächste woche begrüßt sie meine kollegin
eva wannenmacher wenn der kulturplatz
den schweizer maler und grafiker franz
gertsch zum neunzigsten würdigt und hier
geht's jetzt weiter mit dem
diamantenfieber bei gartenbau tschüss
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen die kultur
swisslos